hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my rogue one video for all the
Easter eggs the references to the other
films in the Canon they even had stuff
from the TV shows in there too so here
we go just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the movie yet the IMAX
giveaway is still going on all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video be sure to
click that Bell to enable alert so that
you don't miss out on anything
so there's a whole lot of the other
movies inside this movie it features a
lot of characters that show up during
episode 4 but the title itself is an
Easter Egg for Rogue Squadron rogue one
is sort of like the beginning of the
idea for Rogue Squadron like they say in
the movie there is no rogue one well
there is now so it's sort of the birth
of that Rogue Squadron would go on to
become the most elite fighter unit
inside the rebellion and then eventually
the New Republic during the expanded
universe novels the villain Orson cranek
were a white uniform that's kind of an
Easter Egg for Grand Admiral Thrawn from
the expanded universe but there are
other Imperials that wear white uniforms
his special elite troopers called death
troopers wearing the black uniforms or
actually an Easter egg from Jedi Knight
to Jedi Outcast the video game where
they appeared as death troopers for the
first time so there are even Easter eggs
for the video games in here the really
old video games - Maz Mickelson's
character named Galen is also named
after Galen Marek Starkiller from the
Force Unleashed Starkiller was Darth
Vader's apprentice so just all looping
it back around the saw Guerrera
character was featured during season 5
of the Clone Wars he's also getting
ready to show up on Star Wars rebels so
speaking of which there are a bunch of
Star Wars rebels Easter eggs the ghost
shows up on Yavin 4 when they land it's
on another landing pad just sitting
there
that's captain by syndulla who is
general syndulla gets a shout out during
rogue one like you literally hear
someone call for general syndulla so for
those that don't know rogue one happens
after the events of Star Wars rebels so
she's risen in the ranks of the rebels
to become a general when they learn
about the rebels going to the Imperial
archives to steal the Death Star plans
chopper rolls by Mon Mothma and then
during the battle a little bit
later in the movie you see the ghost
enter the fray so like it's here in this
big star field here then you hear the
character pow
shout one of Zeb's famous curse words
karabast
as he's charging the beach so this last
one's a bit of a stretch but the
hammerhead Corvette that gets the shout
out that belongs to Princess Leia
obviously a big reference to what
happens at the beginning of episode 4
but during the events of Star Wars
rebels they explain how the rebellion
comes into possession of those in how
Princess Leia gets one herself so a
whole bunch of rebels in there they
ended up using a bunch of the animated
stuff even though it's very lightly and
kind of in the background but then you
have very big things like Kyber crystals
which actually started out in splinter
of the mind's eye the crystals that most
Jedi use inside their lightsabers being
refined and used to power the Death Star
laser so that is why the super laser is
green there was also some abandoned
storyline from George Lucas when he was
first conceiving of episode 4 who used
the Kyber crystal as a sort of MacGuffin
but that storyline was abandoned and it
became the Death Star plans there was
the blue milk at the beginning of the
film sort of like Luke Skywalker's
beginning living with a brew and uncle
Owen before things went sideways the
appeals came didn't quite end with the
charred skeletons that they did in
Episode four but you may have noticed
that mon mothma
the actress that played her was the same
one who played her during Revenge of the
Sith it was actually a deleted scene so
you might not have actually seen in the
movie if you didn't have the DVD but
it's another one of those obi-wan Kenobi
Ewan McGregor situations whereby an
actor plays a younger version of a
character they get a little bit older in
real life but the characters themselves
are also aged up in these new movies so
in real life she becomes a more
age-appropriate mon mothma
for the time period of this movie you
may have recognized Barristan Selmy from
Game of Thrones there were a lot of
familiar faces from genre TV but he was
playing general Jam to Donna who is a
very big figure during Episode four then
of course you all recognize Jimmy Smits
as Bail Organa coming back from the
prequels so he made a number of
references to other people as he was
leaving to go back to Alderaan too bad
we know how that ends but he talks about
trusting someone with his life he's
talking about his daughter Princess Leia
who they brought back just like grand
moff tarkin with did
reproduction in the Jedi that he was
going to contact was obi-wan Kenobi in
hiding on Tatooine waiting for Luke
Skywalker to come of age things were
happening pretty quickly at the end of
the film so if he didn't pick up on it
they were like literally taking the
plans to Princess Leia just barely got
there is Darth Vader was slicing them
down and as they're pulling away from
the wreckage he chases them down in the
opening moments of Episode four so
effectively what you could do the way
this is designed is that you can make a
super cut by just jamming rogue one in
Episode four together and there'd be a
seamless transition between the end of
that movie in the beginning of episode
four
who could forget walrus man Jin actually
bumps into dr. Cornelius in walrus man
who are just as big of before
he runs into obi-wan Kenobi in the
cantina and they both get themselves
killed so there were a ton of people in
this movie that showed up right before
you knew they were getting ready to die
during Episode four so let's talk about
grand moff tarkin coming back this is
actually reportedly some of the changes
they made late on in the film decided to
add a lot more of him but whether you
guys liked it or not they totally
brought him back to life with a digital
reproduction I really think that if
you're a younger person seeing this
movie it probably didn't bother you as
much but if you're an older person and
you understand that the actor that
playing him died a long time ago then it
gets a little bit weird so if you can
jump over that hurdle I think it was
okay
just as long as they don't do this all
the time like I don't want to see Anakin
and like every character that's ever
died come back as a digital reproduction
in every single movie more empire stuff
this actually gets really cool Vader's
castle on mu stefarr so this is actually
taken from original art that Ralph
McQuarrie did before Return of the Jedi
that was then later scrapped
he had a palace that was supposed to be
on a volcano planet later George Lucas
made the prequels that became mu stefarr
so that is where his temple is how
fitting that he build it on the side of
that epic fight with obi-wan Kenobi the
bhakta tank was also a really nice touch
too it's not necessarily an easter egg
for Empire Strikes Back Luke in the
bhakta tank but it definitely invokes a
lot of that imagery the temple that
Donnie Yen and the other people were
supposed to be guarding before the wills
all went away or
Bart killed is actually a reference to
the Wills the George Lucas originally
wrote into his first Star Wars treatment
it was originally called The Adventures
of Luke Starkiller as taken from the
journals of the Wills so nice real big
deep cut for original George Lucas stuff
they do that a lot they'll try to
include little Easter eggs from things
that George Lucas cut out a long time
ago from his original scripts or from
original Ralph McQuarrie art like Darth
Vader's Palace there were all kinds of
verbal references to jokes from other
people in the Star Wars franchise like
hey - heh so making the joke about the
odds of him being shot with her blaster
they're high very high in that we have
to talk about all those names that Jenn
read off when they were looking for the
Stardust plans in the archive so she's
scrolling down a bunch of random names
for plans of buildings and projects and
finally says black saber there was a
giant group of people in my theater that
screamed when they said that name people
are like are they talking about the dark
saber what's going on here is this
something that's going to come back into
the Canon because there is no such thing
as black saber in the Star Wars universe
right now so that's really just them
teasing something coming they could have
been talking about Darth Vader's super
stardestroyer the executor but that's
probably not it it's probably just
something else that they're throwing out
there that they can pick up and run with
in the new films so the dark saber is a
black bladed lightsaber that was
constructed during the Old Republic era
then was stolen by Mandalorians and
appeared during the Clone Wars
episodes when obi-wan Kenobi was on
Mandalore later it passed into the
possession of Darth Maul who then
brought it back on Star Wars rebels
recently in a recent episode so the dark
saber has made it full circle so just
remember that archive is an archive of
all the giant buildings and big
construction projects that the Empire is
building so whatever black saber is it's
some giant project so there was a book
in the expanded universe called dark
saber that was basically like a smaller
version of the Death Star it was mostly
just the super laser with like very
little construction around it so it was
built to look like a giant lightsaber
but you guys can let me know what were
your favorite Easter eggs that you
spotted during rogue
and what do you think that black saber
is a reference to if there were any
easter eggs you guys spotted that I did
not include in the video just write them
below in the comments there were
thousands of visual things really small
behind-the-scenes details that we
probably won't find out about till we
watch the film like a billion more times
I'm still going to be doing a bunch of
Star Wars stuff in the next couple of
weeks but I'm going to wait to do some
more the spoilery stuff till next week
after everybody gets a chance to see the
movie I'll talk about Darth Vader
anthology films and why there's probably
not going to be one really it stems from
the idea of scarcity like there were a
couple Darth Vader lines in the movie
that I felt like we're weird he's better
when he's not talking and just being
super menacing like that in fight when
he just slashing them all down no words
just going to town but I also have a
really cool flash versus iris quest
video that I'm going to post tomorrow
morning and then there'll be some Game
of Thrones Walking Dead on Monday so
I'll just post updates on the video
schedule as I post new videos well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my review of the movie and you
can click here for a couple big DC
trailers that I just dropped thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight me
me me me anything
[Music]
you